Add a pop of culture to every room in your house with SiriusXM. Stream over 425 channels of ad-free music, plus exclusive talk, world-class news, live play-by-play sports, comedy, and popular podcasts with the SXM app. Subscribe to the streaming platinum plan and get your first three months for free. Visit SiriusXM.ca for details.
使用 SiriusXM，为家里的每个房间增添一点文化气息。通过 SXM 应用程序，串流播放超过 425 个无广告音乐频道，以及独家访谈、世界级新闻、现场赛事转播、喜剧和热门播客。订阅串流白金套餐，即可免费享受前三个月。详情请访问 SiriusXM.ca。
SiriusXM, everything you want to hear lives here. MUSIC Our episodes deal with SiriusXM and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website.
SiriusXM，你想听的一切都在这里。音乐我们的节目涉及 SiriusXM 以及往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上本节目的节目说明。
This episode involves a crime against children. It may not be suitable for all listeners. MUSIC If you travel down Rains County Road 2370 in Texas, just outside the city of Emory, you will eventually come across a narrow gravel road. Following the private road is a bumpy and somewhat lonely journey that's surrounded by dense woodland
本 episode 涉及针对儿童的犯罪。可能不适合所有听众。音乐如果您沿着德克萨斯州雷恩斯县 2370 号公路行驶，就在埃默里市郊外，您最终会遇到一条狭窄的碎石路。沿着这条私人道路是一段颠簸且有些孤独的旅程，四周环绕着茂密的林地
and tall pine trees hang overhead, forming a canopy above you. The graveled Ring Road has two properties situated 400 yards apart from one another. Aside from that, there is nothing but thick forest and the sound of birdsong to welcome a weary driver. It's peaceful. At the entry to one property, Max, a black Labrador, waits patiently.
高大的松树悬在头顶，在您上方形成了一个树冠。铺满碎石的环形路有两处房产，彼此相距 400 码。除此之外，只有茂密的森林和鸟鸣声欢迎疲惫的司机。这里很平静。在一个房产的入口处，一只名叫马克斯的黑色拉布拉多犬正在耐心地等待。
He's a loyal dog who takes it upon himself to protect his family at all costs. Max sits next to the remains of what was once a beloved family home. There is rubble everywhere, and some members are still hot on his pawpads as he walks through the ashes. A sign, one of the few things that wasn't destroyed in the blaze, is visible amongst the debris.
它是一只忠诚的狗，不惜一切代价保护自己的家人。马克斯坐在曾经深爱的家庭住宅的废墟旁。到处都是瓦砾，当他走过灰烬时，有些余温依然灼烧着他的肉垫。在废墟中可以看到一个牌子，这是火灾中少数未被烧毁的东西之一。
Engraved on split cedar wood, the sign announces the family that resided in the home, reading The Cafes in large letters. Besided is engraved Joshua chapter 24 verse 15, a scripture from the Bible which in part reads, If it seem evil unto you to serve the Lord, choose ye this day whom you will serve. But, as for me and my house, we will serve the Lord.
牌子上刻着分生雪松木，宣布了居住在这所房子里的家庭，上面用大写字母写着 The Caffes。旁边刻着约书亚记第 24 章第 15 节，这是一段圣经经文，部分内容写道：“若是你们以侍奉耶和华为不好，今日就可以选择所要侍奉的；至于我和我家，我们必定侍奉耶和华。”
Well-wishers concerned about Max's welfare sneak under the police tape to bring him food and water, but Max isn't interested. It's Monday, March 3, 2008, two days since the fire that destroyed the cafe house, and Max is still waiting. He's waiting for his family. Two years earlier, Terry and Penny Caffee proudly displayed
关心马克斯状况的好心人溜过警察的警戒线给他送食物和水，但马克斯并不感兴趣。那是 2008 年 3 月 3 日星期一，距离摧毁咖啡之家的火灾已经过去两天了，马克斯仍在等待。他在等他的家人。两年前，特里和佩妮·卡菲自豪地展示了
the sign that says, If it seem evil unto you to serve the Lord, choose ye this day whom you will serve. But, as for me and my house, it seems evil unto you to serve the Lord. Well-wishers concerned about Max's welfare, it seems evil unto you to serve the Lord. Well-wishers concerned about Max's welfare,
写着“若是你们以侍奉耶和华为不好，今日就可以选择所要侍奉的；至于我和我家，我们以侍奉耶和华为不好”的牌子。关心马克斯状况的好心人，以侍奉耶和华为不好。关心马克斯状况的好心人，
Penny Caffee proudly displayed the split Cedarwood sign at the entrance to their new home. Made for them by their good friend and only neighbour, Tommy Gaston, the sign, complete with a meaningful bible quote, was a fitting gift for the religious family. Their 20-acre property was situated approximately 60 miles north of Dallas,
佩妮·卡菲在新家入口处自豪地展示了这块分裂的雪松木牌匾。这块牌子由他们的好朋友兼唯一的邻居托米·加斯顿为他们制作，上面刻有意味深长的圣经名言，是对这个宗教家庭的一份贴切的礼物。他们的 20 英亩房产位于达拉斯以北约 60 英里处，
in the tiny town of Alba. It offered the cafe family ample room to play and explore. When Terry Caffee heard from his friend Tommy that the house had become available, he jumped at the chance to purchase it. Now, as he watched his youngest son Tyler play on a rope swing in their front yard, he knew he had made the right decision.
在小镇阿尔巴。它为卡菲一家提供了充足的玩耍和探索空间。当特里·卡菲从朋友托米那里得知这栋房子空出来时，他毫不犹豫地买下了它。现在，看着他的小儿子泰勒在他们前院的绳索秋千上玩耍，他知道自己做出了正确的决定。
The cafe family quickly settled in. The move placed them even closer to their family church, the Miracle Faith Baptist Church, and Penny homeschooled their three children, Erin, Matthew and Tyler. The layout of the two-story cabin-style home meant that Terry and Penny could sleep downstairs while the children had the upstairs largely to themselves,
卡菲一家很快安顿下来。这次搬家使他们离他们的家庭教堂——奇迹信仰浸信会教堂更近了，佩妮在家教育他们的三个孩子艾琳、马修和泰勒。这栋两层楼的小木屋风格的住宅的布局意味着特里和佩妮可以睡在楼下，而孩子们的楼上则主要由他们自己使用，
offering everyone space and privacy. Terry worked long hours delivering medical equipment to people who required it at their homes. Although he enjoyed his job, he felt he could relax when he took the turnoff to the private road he shared with Tommy Gaston and his wife Helen. Terry's 14-year-old daughter Erin
为每个人提供空间和隐私。特里工作时间很长，为需要医疗设备的人送货上门。尽管他很喜欢这份工作，但当他拐向与托米·加斯顿和他的妻子海伦共用的私人道路时，他觉得可以放松下来。特里 14 岁的女儿艾琳
often ran out the front door to welcome him home, give him a hug, and inquire about his day. His wife Penny met him at the door each night with a smile and a kiss. Terry Caffee was living his dream. Terry met Penny in 1989 at a church service. They went on their first date a week later, and in eight months, the two were married.
经常跑出前门欢迎他回家，给他一个拥抱，并询问他的一天过得怎么样。他的妻子佩妮每天晚上都带着微笑和吻在门口迎接他。特里·卡菲过着他的梦想生活。特里于 1989 年在一次礼拜中遇到了佩妮。一周后他们进行了第一次约会，八个月后两人结婚了。
Terry and Penny wanted nothing more than to start a family. Their wish was fulfilled in July 1991 when they welcomed their daughter Erin into the world. In June 1994, the family of three expanded with the birth of son Matthew. Five years later, in April 1999, another son, Tyler, came along. Deeply religious, the Caffee family were described
特里和佩妮最希望的就是组建一个家庭。1991 年 7 月，他们迎来了女儿艾琳的降生，他们的愿望实现了。1994 年 6 月，随着儿子马修的出生，这个三口之家扩大了。五年后的 1999 年 4 月，另一个儿子泰勒出生了。卡菲一家有着深厚的宗教信仰，被
by Alba locals as good Christians who embodied the All-American family. Prior to the birth of his children, Terry had spent time working with youth in his church when he felt a higher calling from God. He began studying to become a minister with his goal to become a pastor or evangelist and spread the word of God.
阿尔巴当地人描述为体现了全美家庭的好基督徒。在孩子出生之前，特里曾花时间在教堂与年轻人一起工作，当时他感到了来自上帝的更高召唤。他开始学习成为一名牧师，目标是成为一名牧师或布道家并传播上帝的话语。
Penny, on the other hand, devoted her time to playing in the church gospel band. A gifted pianist who played every day, Penny also performed at other area churches and recorded albums with family friend Tommy Gaston. When she wasn't practicing piano, doing household chores or homeschooling the children, Penny volunteered her time delivering meals
另一方面，佩妮将她的时间奉献给了在教堂福音乐队中演奏。作为一名每天弹奏的天赋钢琴家，佩妮还曾在其他地区的教堂演出，并与家庭朋友托米·加斯顿录制专辑。不练习钢琴、做家务或在家教育孩子时，佩妮会自愿花时间送饭
to the sick and elderly. The three Caffee children were vastly different from one another. The youngest child, Tyler, was a shy boy with an adventurous streak. He loved nothing more than jumping into the pond on the Caffee property, much to the concern of his careful mother.
给病人和老人。卡菲家的三个孩子截然不同。最小的孩子泰勒是一个害羞但富有冒险精神的男孩。他最喜欢跳进卡菲家的池塘里，这让小心翼翼的母亲非常担心。
Middle child Matthew was affectionately known as Bubba due to his size and stature. Although large, Matthew was a kind and gentle boy who loved playing the harmonica and guitar, as well as journaling. Oldest sibling, Aaron, inherited her mother's long-blonde hair and sparkling eyes. At 4 foot 11, Aaron made her presence known
由于体型和身高，中间的孩子马修被亲切地称为巴巴。虽然身材魁梧，但马修是一个善良温和的男孩，喜欢弹奏口琴和吉他，还喜欢写日记。最大的姐姐阿伦继承了母亲的长金发和闪亮的眼睛。身高 4 英尺 11 英寸的阿伦展现了她的存在感
with her loud but angelic voice that echoed around the church walls. According to the Texas Monthly, Aaron's pastor joked that if he had five Aaron Caffees, he would fill his church on Sundays. Boys followed the teen wherever she went and attended Miracle Faith Baptist Church just to see her. Her father, Terry, would lovingly tell her
她那洪亮而天使般的声音在教堂的墙壁间回荡。据《德克萨斯月刊》报道，阿伦的牧师开玩笑说，如果他有五个阿伦·卡菲，他周日就能坐满教堂。无论这个十几岁的女孩走到哪里，男孩们都追随着她，并来到奇迹信仰浸信会教堂只为见她一面。她的父亲特里深情地告诉她
that her voice was so beautiful, he wanted her to sing at his funeral. The Caffee family finished 2007 excited for the future. In April 2008, Terry was due to finish his studies and fulfill his dream of being ordained in the ministry. The children were doing well in their studies. Now, 16-year-old Aaron had attended a youth camp where she was voted most likely to succeed
她的声音太美了，他希望她在他的葬礼上唱歌。卡菲一家对未来充满期待地结束了 2007 年。2008 年 4 月，特里即将完成学业，实现被按立为牧师的梦想。孩子们的学业进展顺利。现在，16 岁的阿伦参加了一个青年营，在那里她被投票选为最有可能成功的人
and most fun-loving person. Then, Charlie Wilkinson entered the picture. 18-year-old Charlie entered the Sonic Fast Food Restaurant in Emory. He noticed Aaron Caffee working as a waitress and was immediately attracted to her. She had just started working there part-time to gain some independence and earn a small amount of money. Charlie caught her eye also and the pair began to talk.
以及最爱玩的人。然后，查理·威尔金森进入了画面。18 岁的查理进入了埃默里的索尼克快餐店。他注意到阿伦·卡菲正在当女服务员，并立即被她吸引。她刚刚开始在那里做兼职以获得一些独立性并赚取少量金钱。查理也吸引了她的目光，两人开始交谈。
Charlie began dropping by on Aaron's work breaks to see her. A few weeks later, he worked up the courage to ask her out. Aaron, whom friends described as naive and sheltered, happily gave Charlie her number. They soon began dating. Aaron had casually dated before, but this was her first serious relationship. Aaron and Charlie's romance started with long phone calls to one another.
查理开始在阿伦的工作间隙顺便来看她。几周后，他鼓起勇气约她出去。朋友们形容阿伦天真而受庇护，她高兴地把自己的电话号码给了查理。他们很快开始约会。阿伦以前曾随意约过会，但这是她的第一段严肃恋情。阿伦和查理的浪漫始于彼此的长途电话。
Then, Charlie would come to the cafe home after school. He draped himself across their furniture and made a nuisance of himself when the cafes were doing household chores. From the book, Terror by Night, his constant presence in the house irritated Terry. He found Charlie to be disrespectful and a know-it-all. He swore around Terry's children and didn't have a job, although he did intend on joining the army when he finished his schooling.
然后，查理会在放学后去咖啡馆的家。当咖啡馆一家人在做家务时，他懒洋洋地躺在他们的家具上，惹是生非。根据《午夜惊魂》一书，他在家里的不断出现惹恼了特里。他发现查理不尊重人而且是个万事通。他在特里的孩子面前说脏话，而且没有工作，尽管他确实打算在完成学业后加入军队。
Penny tried to reassure her husband that Charlie seemed nice and was probably harmless. However, agreed that they should keep a close eye on the young couple. In mid-January 2008, Aaron came to her parents with a request. She asked if she could transfer from homeschooling to a high school so she could be with other peers her own age and make friends. Terry and Penny agreed, hoping that the move would distance her from Charlie, who seemed to spend all his spare time with Aaron.
佩妮试图向丈夫保证，查理看起来人很好，可能没有恶意。然而，（他们）同意应该密切关注这对年轻情侣。2008 年 1 月中旬，阿伦带着一个请求来到父母面前。她问自己是否可以从在家上学转到高中，这样她就可以和其他同龄同伴在一起并结交朋友。特里和佩妮同意了，希望这一举动能让她远离似乎把所有空闲时间都花在阿伦身上的查理。
She enrolled in Reigns High School. Terry and Penny were dismayed to learn that Charlie also attended the school as a senior. Aaron and Charlie stopped socializing with other students and became inseparable at school, sometimes going to Aaron's old Chevy pickup truck to fool around over the lunch break. Charlie also began attending the Miracle Faith Baptist Church with Aaron. The pair were always seen holding hands throughout the services. Parishioners commented to Terry and Penny that their daughter had a bad case of puppy love.
她入读了雷恩斯高中。特里和佩妮惊恐地发现查理也是学校的高年级学生。阿伦和查理停止与其他学生交往，在学校里形影不离，有时会去阿伦的旧雪佛龙皮卡车里在午休时间胡闹。查理还开始和阿伦一起去奇迹信仰浸信会教堂。在整个礼拜期间，总能看到两人手牵着手。教区居民向特里和佩妮评论说，他们的女儿得了严重的幼犬恋爱症。
Terry was concerned. Charlie's friends also noticed how much his relationship with Aaron had changed him. He talked about her non-stop. Gushing about his love for her. Aaron couldn't understand why her parents didn't approve of their relationship. Charlie was known to be a bit of a hothead, but was generally well behaved. He didn't cause any trouble at school, aside from the odd occasion where he was asked to remove his cowboy hat for class.
特里很担心。查理的朋友们也注意到他与阿伦的关系改变了他多少。他不停地谈论她。滔滔不绝地表达他对她的爱。阿伦不明白为什么她的父母不赞成他们的关系。查理有点脾气暴躁，但总体表现良好。他在学校没有惹任何麻烦，除了偶尔被要求在课堂上摘下牛仔帽的奇特场合。
One day in January 2008, Charlie and Aaron went out for an early dinner. As mentioned in the Texas Monthly, on the way home, Charlie pulled over his run down Ford Explorer and asked Aaron to hop out of the car. On a deserted road, he bent down on one knee and presented Aaron with an expensive and intricate ring. Once his grandmother's engagement ring, Charlie offered the ring to Aaron as a sign of their friendship and his promise to always be hers. It wasn't a formal proposal, but by giving her the ring, Charlie made it clear that he wanted to propose when the time was right. Aaron accepted and later spent the night at church proudly showing the ring to her friends
2008 年 1 月的一天，查理和阿伦出去吃早晚餐。正如《德克萨斯月刊》所提到的，在回家的路上，查理把车停在他那辆破旧的福特探险者旁边，让阿伦下车。在一条荒凉的路上，他单膝下跪，向阿伦呈上一枚昂贵而复杂的戒指。这枚戒指曾是他祖母的订婚戒指，查理把它送给阿伦，作为他们友谊的象征以及他永远属于她的承诺。这不是一次正式的求婚，但通过送她这戒指，查理明确表示他想在时机成熟时求婚。阿伦接受了，后来在教堂度过了一夜，自豪地向朋友们展示这戒指
in the congregation. Terry found out about the ring from a fellow parishioner and was furious with Charlie, confronting him about it after church. Charlie agreed to go to the cafe home the following night. Terry wanted to lay down some ground rules. Terry, Penny, Charlie and Aaron sat around the dining table. Both teams listened intently as Terry told Charlie that he was no longer permitted to come around to see Aaron every night. Instead, he could visit one night a week and had to leave by 9pm. Given that the pair saw each other every weekday at school, Aaron's parents saw this as a fair and reasonable request. Although not thrilled with the decision, the young couple agreed.
在会众中。特里从一位教友那里知道了这枚戒指的事情，对查理大发雷霆，并在礼拜后当面质问他。查理同意第二天晚上去卡菲家。特里想立下一些基本规矩。特里、佩妮、查理和阿伦坐在餐桌旁。两个团队聚精会神地听着特里告诉查理，他不再被允许每晚都来看阿伦。相反，他一周只能来一次，并且必须在晚上 9 点前离开。鉴于两人每个工作日在学校都会见面，阿伦的父母认为这是一个公平合理的请求。虽然对这个决定并不兴奋，但这对年轻情侣还是同意了。
For a while, things at the cafe home went back to normal. Charlie continued to see Aaron at church, the pair even singing solo parts one night. However, Terry and Penny noticed a difference in their daughter. She seemed withdrawn and the happy go lucky friendly Aaron began snapping back at them in conversations. She lost interest in her appearance, leaving the house without doing her hair and makeup, completely out of character. When Charlie visited, he regarded the cafe family coolly. There was tension in the cafe household when he was around. On February 27, 2008, Penny Cafe sat nervously at the public library. The cafe family did not have a computer at home, so relied on public or family members'
有一段时间，卡菲家的事情恢复了正常。查理继续在教堂见到阿伦，两人甚至在一个晚上合唱了独唱部分。然而，特里和佩妮注意到他们的女儿发生了变化。她显得离群索居，原本无忧无虑、友好的阿伦开始在谈话中对他们顶嘴。她对自己的外表失去了兴趣，出门不整理头发和化妆，这完全不符合她的性格。查理来访时，冷淡地看着卡菲一家。他在的时候，卡菲家里弥漫着紧张气氛。2008 年 2 月 27 日，佩妮·卡菲紧张地坐在公共图书馆里。卡菲家里没有电脑，因此每次需要上网时都依赖公共电脑或家庭成员的
computers every time they needed to access the internet. Penny searched for Charlie Wilkinson's MySpace page, and what she saw horrified her. She called Terry in tears, explaining that her sister had told her that Aaron had been on Charlie's MySpace at her house and forgotten to log out of her account. According to Tara by night, Terry dropped what he was doing to join his wife at the library. The two read posts on Charlie's page, including one comment telling Charlie to bring his bitch of a girlfriend over for the weekend so they could get drunk and have sex. Terry and Penny confronted Aaron about the MySpace page later that night. She bowed her head and stared at the floor, as Terry told Aaron she was not allowed to see Charlie
电脑。佩妮搜索了查理·威尔金森的 MySpace 页面，她看到的景象吓坏了她。她哭着打电话给特里，解释说她的姐姐告诉她，阿伦在她家登过查理的 MySpace 且忘记退出账号了。据《午夜惊魂》报道，特里放下手头的工作，赶往图书馆与妻子汇合。两人阅读了查理页面上的帖子，其中包括一条评论，告诉查理带上他那讨厌的女朋友过来过周末，这样他们就可以喝醉并发生性行为。那天晚上晚些时候，特里和佩妮就 MySpace 页面一事质问了阿伦。她低下头盯着地板，特里告诉阿伦，她不准再见查理
again. Deeply concerned, he told Aaron that when she was 18 she was free to make her own decisions, but in the meantime he was looking out for her and doing what he thought was right. Aaron burst into tears, but her response surprised him. She told her father, I've wanted to break up with the Charlie for a while, but I just don't know how to do it. Aaron broke it off with the Charlie later that night after a church service. At the behest of her father, Aaron chose a public place where she would be safe in case Charlie lost his temper. Parishioners watched on as Charlie slammed his car door and sped out of the church car park, tyres squealing. On Friday, February 29, two days after Aaron had called things off
了。他深感担忧地告诉阿伦，当她 18 岁时，她可以自由做出自己的决定，但在此期间，他在照顾她，做他认为正确的事。阿伦失声痛哭，但她的反应让他感到意外。她告诉父亲：“我想和查理分手有一段时间了，但我只是不知道该怎么做。”那天晚些时候，在一次礼拜结束后，阿伦与查理断绝了关系。在父亲的敦促下，阿伦选择了一个公共场所，以防查理发脾气时她能保持安全。教区居民在一旁看着查理砰地关上车门，轮胎发出刺耳的摩擦声，疾驰着驶出教堂停车场。在 2 月 29 日星期五，即阿伦与查理一刀两断两天后，
with Charlie, Terry drove down the graveled road to home. From terror by night, it was pitch black and Terry was exhausted from working a 14 and a half hour day. He reheated some dinner and his sons Matthew and Tyler giggled as Terry accidentally spilled some on the floor and fell in it. Terry cleaned up the mess and tickled the boys as they wrestled. Aaron, who had been happy and content since the breakup, joined in and a pillow fight ensued. Afterwards, Terry kissed all his children goodnight and went to bed. At around 5am the next morning, Terry's neighbour Tommy Gaston awoke to a strange banging coming from the front door. It started as a soft thud but became louder and more insistent
特里开车沿着碎石路回家。根据《午夜惊魂》，当时漆黑一片，特里因为工作了 14 个半小时而筋疲力尽。他重新加热了一些晚饭，他的儿子们马修和泰勒咯咯地笑了起来，因为特里不小心把一些饭菜洒在地板上并摔倒在上面。特里收拾了残局，并在男孩们摔跤时逗他们笑。自分手以来一直快乐满足的阿伦也加入了进来，随后爆发了一场枕头大战。之后，特里亲吻了他所有的孩子道晚安并上床睡觉。第二天早上 5 点左右，特里的邻居托米·加斯顿被前门传来的奇怪敲门声吵醒了。起初是沉闷的轻击声，但变得越来越响亮、越来越急促
as Tommy rose to investigate. Aside from what Tommy and his wife Helen assumed was an early morning storm with thunder rolling in the distance, the two had slept peacefully through the night. Tommy opened his front door. Lying on the ground of the porch was Terry Caffey who had used his forearm to bang on the door. Although it was a freezing cold night, Terry was only wearing a t-shirt, pajama pants and one wet sock. He was covered in blood and dirt so much so that it was impossible to tell where the bleeding was coming from. Spluttering, he told Tommy that he and his family had been shot at and the house set a light. He was the only one to make it out alive. Tommy and Helen assisted Terry and called 911.
随着托米起身查看。除了托米和他的妻子海伦认为是一场远处滚滚雷声的清晨风暴之外，两人安稳地睡了整晚。托米打开了前门。躺在门廊地上的是特里·卡菲，他曾用前臂敲击门。尽管是个寒冷的夜晚，特里却只穿着一件 T 恤、睡裤和一只湿袜子。他浑身是血和泥土，以至于无法分辨血是从哪里流出来的。他结结巴巴地告诉托米，他和他的家人遭到了枪击，房子被点燃了。他是唯一活着逃出来的人。托米和海伦协助了特里并拨打了 911。
Once inside, the warmth of the home brought Terry to his senses and the pain from his injuries kicked in. Paramedics arrived and as Terry was loaded into the ambulance, he was met with Detective Richard Elman from the Rains County Sheriff's Department. He gasped to the detective, I don't think I'm going to make it. Meanwhile, firefighters arrived at the Caffey house and were confronted by a blaze that had engulfed the entire building. Once they had contained the fire, investigators combed through the ashes and rubble. They soon located who they believed to be Penny, Erin, Matthew and Tyler and sent their bones away for examination. The family dog, Max, could not be coaxed from the
一旦进入室内，房子的温暖使特里恢复了清醒，伤口的疼痛也随之袭来。医护人员赶到，当特里被抬上救护车时，他遇到了雷恩斯县治安官办公室的理查德·埃尔曼侦探。他喘着气对侦探说：“我想我撑不下去了。”与此同时，消防员赶到了卡菲家，面对的是一场吞噬了整栋建筑的大火。一旦控制了火势，调查人员便在灰烬和瓦砾中仔细搜寻。他们很快锁定了他们认为是佩妮、艾琳、马修和泰勒的人，并把他们的骨头送去检查。家里的狗马克斯无法被诱离
area, instead standing sentry to the property. Members of the Miracle Faith Baptist Church wept for the Caffey family during the sermon that Sunday morning of March 2. The family's longtime pastor, Todd McGay, he struggled to maintain his composure. He affectionately remembered the Caffey's, who were like family to those in the congregation. Quote, I don't even think I would have crawled out of the house, but God had a purpose for Terry's life. God has a reason. God gave him the strength to get out. The parishioners mourned the loss of the Caffey family, but there was also a lingering question in their minds. What had gone on that night?
该地区，而是在房产周围站岗。3 月 2 日星期日那天上午的布道期间，奇迹信仰浸信会教堂的成员为卡菲一家痛哭流涕。该家庭长期以来的牧师托德·麦克盖竭力保持镇定。他深情地回忆起卡菲一家，他们对会众来说就像家人一样。引述：“我想我甚至都不会从房子里爬出来，但上帝对特里的人生有旨意。上帝有原因。上帝给了他逃出来的力量。”教区居民哀悼卡菲一家的离世，但他们心中也挥之不去一个疑问。那天晚上到底发生了什么？
Terry Caffey was admitted to the East Texas Medical Center Intensive Care Unit. He had been shot five times, but none of the bullets had penetrated major organs. Several of the wounds had clear entry and exit points, and two bullets were lodged in his right arm. The most severe injury was from a bullet that entered Terry's right cheek, passing through his sinus cavities before exiting out his left ear canal. Drifting in and out of consciousness due to shock and painkillers, surgeons waited until Terry was stable enough to undergo surgery. When safe to do so, Terry successfully underwent surgery to remove the bullets lodged in his upper body. He regained consciousness, and it became more lucid the following day.
特里·卡菲被送往东德克萨斯医疗中心重症监护室。他身中五枪，但没有一颗子弹击中主要器官。几处伤口有清晰的进出口，两颗子弹卡在他的右手臂里。最严重的伤是有一颗子弹从特里的右脸颊进入，穿过他的鼻窦腔，然后从左耳道穿出。由于休克和止痛药的作用，意识时有时无，外科医生等到特里情况稳定后才为他做手术。在确保安全后，特里成功接受了手术，取出了卡在他上身的子弹。他恢复了意识，第二天变得更加清醒。
Terry's miraculous survival enabled police to understand what exactly had taken place at the Caffey home on Friday, February 29. That night, each family member retired to bed one by one. The house was in total darkness when Terry was roused from his deep sleep by Max, who was barking at the front of the house. He glanced at his alarm clock. It was just past midnight. Assuming Max was hunting a wild animal that had strayed into the yard, Terry rolled over and went back to sleep. A few hours later, a loud noise jolted Terry wide awake. It was the sound of the bedroom door knob hitting the dryer that was located just behind the door. Terry initially thought
特里奇迹般的生还使警方得以了解 2 月 29 日星期五卡菲家里究竟发生了什么。那天晚上，每个家庭成员一个接一个地上床睡觉。当特里被马克斯从深睡眠中唤醒时，房子里一片漆黑，马克斯正在房子前面吠叫。他瞥了一眼闹钟。刚过午夜。特里以为马克斯在追捕一只迷路闯入院子的野生动物，便翻了个身又睡着了。几个小时后，一声巨响把特里惊醒了。那是卧室门把手撞到紧挨着门后面的烘干机的声音。特里最初以为
son Tyler had suffered a nightmare and was coming in to sleep in their bed. He sat up to reassure him when the sound of gunfire rang out. Penny screamed. A black silhouette of a man appeared in their bedroom doorway, highlighted by the kitchen nightlight beyond. Terry could not recognize his features, but did see the gun he held pointed at Penny. He reached out his arm to shield his wife from the gunfire and was struck five times. The final shot hit Terry in the face and he was thrown into the space between the bed and the wall. He lay motionless, facedown on the floor as the gunman approached. He felt someone kick his feet to see if he was dead. Terry squeezed his eyes shut and kept as still as he could.
儿子泰勒做了噩梦，要来他们的床上睡觉。他坐起来安抚他，这时枪声响了起来。佩妮尖叫起来。在厨房夜灯的映衬下，一个男人的黑色剪影出现在他们卧室门口。特里认不出他的长相，但确实看到他手里拿着枪指着佩妮。他伸出胳膊保护妻子免受枪击，结果身中五枪。最后一枪击中了特里的面部，他被抛到了床和墙壁之间的空间。他一动不动地脸朝下躺在地板上，枪手逼近了。他感觉有人踢了他的脚，看看他是不是死了。特里紧闭双眼，尽量保持一动不动。
The gunman made his way out of the bedroom and into the lounge. He was not alone. The intruders began rummaging through the cafe's belongings, taking all the jewelry and cash they could find. They overturned furniture and pulled items from the top of the piano. One slammed his fists on the piano keys. Then they stopped. They could hear screaming coming from upstairs. Terry woke to the taste of blood and gunpowder and realized he had momentarily passed out. He couldn't feel the right side of his body, but knew he had to get up. Using all the strength he could master, Terry lifted his body with his left arm up onto the bed. Penny lay slumped over at the head of the bed in a large pool of blood.
枪手走出卧室，进入客厅。他不是一个人。入侵者开始翻找卡菲家的物品，拿走了他们能找到的所有珠宝和现金。他们掀翻家具，把物品从钢琴顶上拉下来。其中一人用力拍打琴键。然后他们停了下来。他们能听到楼上传来尖叫声。特里在血腥味和火药味中醒来，意识到自己刚才晕厥了。他感觉不到身体的右侧，但他知道自己必须起来。特里用尽全身力气，用左臂将身体撑到床上。佩妮无力地瘫倒在床头，在一大滩血泊中。
His thoughts immediately turned to Matthew, Tyler and Aaron. Terry could hear screaming and then a further round of gunshots coming from upstairs. The house became silent and Terry passed out again. The smell of smoke roused Terry once more. Blood ran into his eyes, making it difficult to see. He tried to make it to the stairs leading to the top floor where his children were located. But by this stage, a fire had well and truly taken hold and the flames made it impossible to progress. Realizing he would never make it upstairs from the inside of the house, Terry escaped through the bathroom window that joined his bedroom.
他的脑海里立刻浮现出马修、泰勒和阿伦。特里听到尖叫声，随后楼上传来新一轮的枪声。房子安静下来，特里再次晕倒。烟味再次唤醒了特里。鲜血流进他的眼睛里，使他很难看清。他试图走到通往楼上孩子们所在顶楼的楼梯。但到了这个阶段，大火已经彻底蔓延开来，火焰使他无法前进。意识到自己绝不可能从房子内部走到楼上，特里从连着他卧室的浴室窗户逃了出去。
The injured Terry fell five feet to the ground below and took cover behind the property's propane tank. He knew he had to reach his three children. Moving to the front of the house, he tried to find an entry point, but the house was engulfed in flames. Terry felt weak and lightheaded. He crawled into the dense forest at the rear of his house and waited for emergency services to respond. Certain that someone would have noticed the blaze from the road or the deafening explosions that rocked the early morning air. As minutes ticked by, Terry realized that nobody was coming. Their house was so remote that even their closest neighbors mistook the sounds for distant thunder.
受伤的特里从五英尺高处跌落到地面的草坪上，躲在物业的丙烷罐后面。他知道自己必须找到三个孩子。他移动到房子前面，试图寻找一个入口，但房子已被大火吞没。特里感到虚弱和头晕目眩。他爬进房子后方的茂密森林里，等待紧急救援人员的响应。他确信有人会从公路上或震撼清晨空气的震耳欲聋的爆炸声中注意到这场大火。随着时间的流逝，特里意识到没有人来。他们的房子太偏僻了，以至于连他们最近的邻居都把声音误认为是远处的雷声。
Terry didn't care if he died as well. He wanted to be reunited with his family in heaven. But he had one more mission to complete. He knew who was responsible for the attack and had to tell someone. Terry began the long trek to his neighbor Tommy's house 400 yards away. Unable to walk for any longer than a few yards at a time, he began crawling through the dense forest, leaving a trail of blood behind him. Every so often, he had to rest, laying his head on logs while he mustered the strength to continue on. Terry fell into an ice-cold creek and struggled to crawl up the bank to get out. Still, he continued, eventually making it to Tommy's porch.
特里不在乎自己是否也会死。他希望能与家人在天堂团聚。但他还有一个任务要完成。他知道谁是袭击的幕后黑手，必须告诉某人。特里开始了前往 400 码外邻居托米家的漫长跋涉。由于一次无法行走超过几码，他开始穿过茂密的森林艰难爬行，留下一路血迹。每隔一会儿，他就得休息一下，把头靠在圆木上，同时积蓄继续前行的力量。特里跌入冰冷的溪流中，挣扎着爬上河岸逃生。尽管如此，他还是继续前进，最终到达了托米的门廊。
Detective Almond rode in the ambulance that escorted Terry to the hospital. He quickly asked Terry questions in case he were to suddenly lose consciousness or pass away. With much difficulty, Terry recounted a critical moment in the attack. He heard screaming coming from the upper level of his home as he lay motionless beside the bed. The voices weren't from the attackers, but were from his son Matthew screaming. Charlie, why are you doing this? No, Charlie, no. It then went silent. Detectives theorized that Charlie Wilkinson had killed the Caffe family in retaliation for Aaron breaking up with him.
阿尔蒙侦探坐在护送特里去医院的救护车里。他迅速向特里提问，以防他突然失去意识或离世。特里费力地回忆起袭击中的一个关键时刻。当他一动不动地躺在床边时，他听到楼上传来尖叫声。声音不是来自袭击者，而是来自他的儿子马修的尖叫声。“查理，你为什么要这么做？不，查理，不。”随后一片寂静。侦探们推测，查理·威尔金森杀死卡菲一家是为了报复阿伦和他分手。
Chief Deputy Sheriff Kurt Fischer Deputy Sheriff Kurt Fischer already knew where Charlie was staying. Being a small town where everyone knew one another, he had seen Charlie's car parked outside his friend Charles Wade's trailer that morning. He returned to the blue trailer with Deputy Sheriff Ed Emig and knocked on the door. Charles Wade's brother answered. He was unsure if Charlie Wilkinson had spent the night in his trailer but let the officers in to have a look around. The trailer was in disarray with clothes and beer cans strewn about. Deputy Sheriff Fischer came across Charles Wade and his girlfriend
副警长库尔特·费舍尔副警长库尔特·费舍尔已经知道查理住在哪里。作为一个每个人都互相认识的小镇，那天早上他看到查理的车停在他朋友查尔斯·韦德的拖车外面。他带着副警长埃德·埃米格回到那辆蓝色拖车前并敲了敲门。查尔斯·韦德的兄弟应门。他不确定查理·威尔金森是否在拖车里过夜，但还是让警官们进去四处看看。拖车里一片混乱，衣服和啤酒罐散落各处。副警长费舍尔遇到了查尔斯·韦德和他的女友
Bobby Johnson sleeping in one room. According to the Texas Monthly, he continued down the hallway of the trailer when he came across a room with a blanket hanging on the door. Pulling it aside, he shone his flashlight into the room and found Charlie Wilkinson lying awake on his bed. He was wearing blue jeans with no shirt. A semi-automatic handgun lay on the floor beside him. Deputy Sheriff Fischer handcuffed Charlie to take him in for questioning. He denied being anywhere near the cafe property the night before, explaining he had gotten drunk and passed out in the trailer. Deputy Sheriff Emig went back into the trailer to retrieve some clothes for him to put on. When he picked up his cowboy boots, they were covered in blood spatter.
博比·约翰逊在一个房间里睡觉。据《德克萨斯月刊》报道，他继续沿着拖车的走廊走，来到一个门上挂着毯子的房间。他把它拉开，把手电筒照进房间，发现查理·威尔金森正醒着躺在床上。他穿着蓝色牛仔裤，没有穿衬衫。他身旁的地板上放着一把半自动手枪。副警长费舍尔给查理戴上手铐，带他去接受审讯。他否认前一天晚上在卡菲家附近，解释说自己在拖车里喝醉并晕倒了。副警长埃米格回到拖车里为他拿几件衣服穿。当他捡起他的牛仔靴时，靴子上溅满了血迹。
While holding Charlie at the county jail for questioning, Deputy Sheriff Fischer obtained a search warrant and went back to the trailer. In the living room, he found a purse. The driver's license inside belonged to Aaron Caffey. He returned to the bedroom Charlie Wilkinson had been sleeping in and began searching for more evidence to tie him to the attack. He picked up a long-slaved button-up shirt from the floor and a used condom fell out. Fischer moved the blanket that was lying on the floor near the closet. As he did, he saw a wave of long-blonde hair. Thinking it was a wig, he pulled it aside. He got a shock when he realized it wasn't a wig at all. The hair was attached to a person.
在县监狱扣留查理进行审讯期间，副警长费舍尔获得了搜查令，并返回了拖车。在起居室里，他发现了一个钱包。里面的驾驶执照属于阿伦·卡菲。他回到查理·威尔金森睡觉的卧室，开始寻找更多将他与袭击联系起来的证据。他从地板上拿起一件长袖纽扣衬衫，一个用过的避孕套掉了出来。费舍尔移开了衣柜附近地板上的毯子。正当他这样做时，他看到了一波长金发。他以为这是一个假发，便把它拉开。当他意识到这根本不是假发时，他大吃一惊。头发连着一个人。
It was Aaron Caffey. Fischer studied Aaron as she opened her eyes and scanned the trailer. He brought her into the lounge room, still dressed in the pajamas she was wearing the night before. Aaron was dazed and confused. Fischer asked Aaron how she got to the trailer. She looked around her and asked, where am I? She groggily explained how she had been kidnapped and drugged. The last thing she recalled was two men entering her room in the middle of the night. She smelled smoke and knew the house was on fire. The two men were brandishing swords and ordered Aaron to get out of her bed
那是阿伦·卡菲。费舍尔仔细端详着阿伦，她睁开眼睛扫视着拖车。他把她带到休息室，身上仍然穿着前一天晚上穿的睡服。阿伦神情恍惚、迷茫。费舍尔问阿伦她是怎么来到拖车的。她环顾四周问道：“我在哪儿？”她迷迷糊糊地解释了她是如何被绑架和下药的。她记起的最后一件事情是半夜有两个人进入她的房间。她闻到烟味，知道房子着火了。这两个人挥舞着剑，命令阿伦从床上下来
and to lay face down on the floor. That was the last thing she remembered before being roused by Deputy Sheriff Fischer. Aaron's pupils were dilated and she appeared to be suffering from shock, so Fischer organized for her to be transferred to hospital for assessment. She recalled further details of the night before. She had tried to call Charlie after the fire, but had been unable to reach him. She also recalled drinking something at the trailer, but then passing out. In a frightened voice, Aaron whispered, they're coming to get me. Meanwhile, Terry's sister Mary visited Terry in the ICU to tell him the fantastic news that
并面朝下趴在地板上。那是她在被副警长费舍尔唤醒之前记忆中的最后一件事。阿伦的瞳孔放大，看起来像是处于休克状态，因此费舍尔安排将她转送到医院进行评估。她回忆起前一天晚上的更多细节。大火过后她曾试图给查理打电话，但联系不上他。她还记得在拖车里喝了某种东西，但随后就晕倒了。阿伦用恐惧的声音低声说：“他们来抓我了。”与此同时，特里的姐姐玛丽去重症监护室探望特里，告诉他一个好消息：
Aaron had been found alive with only minimal injuries. Terry was overjoyed. Charlie Wilkinson was questioned and he soon broke down. He openly acknowledged his role in the fire and the murders of Penny, Matthew and Tyler and the attempted murder of Terry, telling detectives, I'm in a lot of trouble. As suspected, Charlie didn't act alone. He named two others, friends Charles Wade and Bobby Johnson as accomplices. However, Charlie was adamant about one aspect of the attack on the Caffe family that detectives had wrong. He did not kidnap Aaron Caffe. She was a willing participant.
阿伦被找到了，还活着，而且只受了轻伤。特里欣喜若狂。查理·威尔金森接受了审讯，他很快崩溃了。他公开承认了自己在纵火、谋杀佩妮、马修和泰勒以及企图谋杀特里中所扮演的角色，并告诉侦探：“我惹上大麻烦了。”正如怀疑的那样，查理并非单独行动。他指认了另外两个人，即同伙朋友查尔斯·韦德和博比·约翰逊。然而，查理对侦探们弄错的卡菲一家遇袭案的一个细节态度坚决。他并没有绑架阿伦·卡菲。她是自愿参与的。
Charlie Wilkinson's version of events on the night of the attack varied significantly to the details provided by Aaron. According to Charlie, the pair had been plotting the night's events for over a month. They even had a codename for the plan, FUBAR, standing for fucked up beyond all recognition. Together, they planned to FUBAR the Caffe family so they could be together. Charlie offered his friends 20-year-old Charles Wade and his girlfriend 18-year-old Bobby Johnson who attended the same high school as Charlie and Aaron $2,000 for their help. Aaron explained that the cache was in a lockbox that they would find inside the house. She would help them open it after the attack. On the night of the murders, Aaron joined in
查理·威尔金森对袭击当晚事件版本的描述与阿伦提供的细节有很大出入。据查理所说，两人密谋当晚的事件已经有一个多月了。他们甚至为这个计划起了一个代号：FUBAR，代表“无可救药的彻底混乱”。他们一起计划 FUBAR 卡菲一家，这样他们就能在一起了。查理向他的朋友、20 岁的查尔斯·韦德以及他的女友、18 岁的博比·约翰逊（她和查理及阿伦读同一所高中）提供 2,000 美元作为他们帮忙的报酬。阿伦解释说，现金在一个他们会在房子里找到的密码箱里。袭击后她会帮他们打开。谋杀当晚，阿伦加入
a pillow fight with her father and brothers. As detailed in the documentary by journalist and television personality Piers Morgan, just before midnight, Charles Wade, Bobby Johnson, and Charlie Wilkinson travelled to the Caffe residence. The men tried to gain entrance to the property while Bobby stayed in the car, but Max the Black Labrador spotted them and became agitated, barking and scaring them off. Aaron moved Max to the back of the house and when the coast was clear, they returned to pick her up. Sitting in the car at a nearby cemetery, Charlie, Aaron, Charles and Bobby discussed the plan for just over an hour. At approximately 4am, they drove back to the Caffe residence
了与父亲和兄弟的枕头大战。正如记者兼电视名人皮尔斯·摩根的纪录片中所详细描述的，午夜刚过，查尔斯·韦德、博比·约翰逊和查理·威尔金森前往卡菲住宅。男人们试图进入该物业，而博比则留在车里，但黑色拉布拉多马克斯发现了他们并变得激动起来，狂吠并将他们吓跑了。阿伦把马克斯移到房子后面，等风平浪静后，他们回来接她。坐在附近墓地的车里，查理、阿伦、查尔斯和博比讨论了这个计划一个多小时。大约凌晨 4 点，他们开车回到卡菲住宅
and parked on the main road. The girls stayed in the backseat of Charles Wade's car as Charlie and Charles wandered down the gravel road and entered through the front door that Aaron had left unlocked for them. They made a beeline for Terry and Penny's bedroom. Charlie shot Terry five times and turned the gun on Penny. He fired a few shots, but the pistol then jammed. Charlie had bought another weapon with him in case of emergency, a long samurai-type sword that he used to cut Penny's throat as she sat in bed. Confident that Aaron's parents were dead, the pair ransacked the lounge area and made their way upstairs to the boys' rooms. Charles Wade led the way. He found 13-year-old Matthew first,
并停在主路上。女孩们坐在查尔斯·韦德汽车的后座上，查理和查尔斯沿着碎石路闲逛，并从阿伦为他们留着没锁的前门走了进去。他们径直走向特里和佩妮的卧室。查理向特里开枪五次，然后将枪转向佩妮。他开了几枪，但手枪卡壳了。查理随身带了另一件武器以防紧急情况，一把长日本武士刀，当佩妮坐在床上时，他用它割断了佩妮的喉咙。确信阿伦的父母已经死了，两人洗劫了休息室，然后上楼去男孩们的房间。查尔斯·韦德带头。他首先找到了 13 岁的马修，
who pleaded with Charlie to stop what he was doing. Charlie told detectives, they were scared and I could not stand to look at their faces. Matthew tried to kick Charlie in self-defense. In response, Charles Wade shot him multiple times. They found eight-year-old Tyler hiding in the back of Aaron's closet. Charles and Charlie then stabbed Tyler to death. The pair then used lighters to set furniture in the house on fire and made a hasty getaway out the front door. On the way, Charlie grabbed a travel bag that Aaron had packed with her belongings. They joined the girls in the car. Charlie told detectives that Aaron smiled at him and said,
他恳求查理停下正在做的事。查理告诉侦探：“他们很害怕，我简直不忍直视他们的脸。”马修试图踢查理进行自卫。作为回应，查尔斯·韦德多次向他开枪。他们发现 8 岁的泰勒躲在阿伦的衣柜后面。查尔斯和查理随后刺死泰勒。两人随后用打火机点燃了房子里的家具，并从前门匆忙逃跑。在路上，查理拿了一个旅行包，那是阿伦收拾好她个人物品的包。他们和车里的女孩会合了。查理告诉侦探，阿伦对她微笑着说：
I'm glad that's over. Charles Wade drove them back to his brother's trailer. Inside, Charlie and Aaron had sex and then went to sleep. Charles Wade and Bobby Johnson were quickly apprehended. They confessed to their involvement in the murders and their stories closely matched the version of events given by Charlie Wilkinson. Charles Wade added that as they drove away from the cafe house, Aaron exclaimed, holy shit, that was awesome. Bobby told detectives that on the night of the attack, Charlie Wilkinson repeatedly asked Aaron to run away with him instead, asking, are you sure you want to do this? Aaron replied, why are you asking me this? If you love me,
“我很高兴这一切都结束了。”查尔斯·韦德开车把他们送回了他兄弟的拖车。在里面，查理和阿伦发生了性关系，然后睡觉了。查尔斯·韦德和博比·约翰逊很快被捕。他们供认了自己参与谋杀，他们的说法与查理·韦德提供的事件版本非常吻合。查尔斯·韦德补充说，当他们开车离开卡菲家时，阿伦大声惊呼：“天哪，太棒了。”博比告诉侦探，在袭击当晚，查理·威尔金森多次要求阿伦和他一起私奔，并问道：“你确定你想这么做吗？”阿伦回答：“你为什么问我这个？如果你爱我……”
you'll do it. As her alleged accomplices were being questioned, Aaron Caffey was assessed in hospital. She stuck to her original story that she had been kidnapped and drugged. According to the documentary, Killer Women with Piers Morgan, Detective Richard Almond spoke to one of the officers waiting with Aaron. He ordered a toxicology screen to check the presence of any drugs in her system that might have been used to sedate or incapacitate her. He also asked the officer to smell the clothes that Aaron had been wearing when apprehended. Had she been in the house at the time of the fire as she maintained, he reasoned that her clothes would smell heavily of smoke.
你会做到的。正当她那些所谓的同谋被讯问时，艾伦·卡菲正在医院接受评估。她坚持自己最初的说法，即她被绑架并被下了药。根据纪录片《皮尔斯·摩根之杀人女性》的记载，理查德·阿尔蒙德警探与其中一名在病房外看守艾伦的警官进行了交谈。他下令进行毒理学筛查，以检查她体内是否存在可能用于镇静或使其失去行动能力的药物。他还要求这位警官闻一闻艾伦被捕时穿的衣服。他推断，如果她像自己坚称的那样在火灾发生时在屋里，她的衣服上会有很浓的烟味。
The officer soon reported back. The toxic screen was clear of any drugs. As for her clothes, they smelled of nothing. She showed no signs of smoke inhalation either. Aaron was discharged from hospital as the interrogations continued with Charlie, Charles and Bobby. Aaron left with Penny's mother, Virginia, who was still dealing with the shock of losing her daughter and grandsons. Their destination was to the East Texas Medical Center to visit Terry. As a likely suspect in a murder investigation, their car was tailed by police. Nearing the hospital, Virginia's car was pulled over. Aaron Caffey was arrested and charged on three counts of capital murder
这位警官很快回来报告了结果。毒理学筛查显示体内没有任何药物。至于她的衣服，上面什么味道也没有。她也没有表现出任何吸入烟气的迹象。随着对查理、查尔斯和博比的审讯继续，艾伦从医院出院了。艾伦跟着彭妮的母亲弗吉尼亚离开了，当时弗吉尼亚仍在承受失去女儿和外孙的巨大打击。他们的目的地是东德克萨斯医疗中心去探望特里。由于她是谋杀案调查中的嫌疑人，他们的汽车遭到了警察的尾随。车子快到医院时，弗吉尼亚的车被拦了下来。艾伦·卡菲被捕，并被指控三项重大谋杀罪。
after Charlie, Charles and Bobby signed statements implicating her in the attack. Aaron was held at a juvenile detention center on a $1.5 million bond. The other three teens were charged with the same counts and held at the Reigns County Jail. As he recovered in hospital, Terry Caffey noticed the staff around the ward acting strangely. Nurses spoke to him without making eye contact and others tried to avoid him altogether. As soon as he thought about it, the pain medication would kick back in and he drift off to sleep. On Monday, March 3, Terry pleaded with his sister to tell him what was wrong. She eventually conceded, telling Terry that Aaron had been arrested and why.
在此之前，查理、查尔斯和博比签署了指控她参与袭击的供词。艾伦被关押在少年拘留中心，保释金为150万美元。另外三名青少年被控相同的罪名，关押在雷恩斯县监狱。在医院恢复期间，特里·卡菲注意到病房周围的工作人员表现得很奇怪。护士们与他说话时不敢有眼神接触，其他人则尽量避开他。每当他想到这一点，止痛药的药效就会上来，他就又会昏昏沉沉地睡过去。3月3日，星期一，特里恳求妹妹告诉他出了什么事。她最终妥协了，告诉特里艾伦被捕的消息以及原因。
Deputy Sheriff Kurt Fischer visited Terry in hospital to tell him the news. Terry asked how his daughter was, explaining that no one would tell him a whole lot and he wasn't allowed to watch the news. Deputy Sheriff Fischer reassured Terry that she was doing fine. Terry then said he didn't want to know a whole lot of details but asked what her level of involvement was. The deputy sheriff paused before responding. Her involvement is great. Terry sobbed as Fischer explained that Aaron was believed to be the mastermind behind the attack on his family. Reigns High School was also feeling the emotional impact of the crime, with word quickly spreading that three of their fellow students had been arrested. Of particular shock was the alleged
副警长库尔特·费舍尔到医院探望特里，将这个消息告诉了他。特里询问女儿的情况，解释说没有人肯告诉他太多细节，而且他不被允许看新闻。副警长费舍尔向特里保证她一切都好。特里接着说他不想知道太多细节，但问她的参与程度有多深。副警长在回答前停顿了一下。她的参与度非常大。费舍尔解释说，据信艾伦是针对他家袭击事件的幕后主使，特里听后失声痛哭。雷恩斯高中也感受到了这起犯罪带来的情感冲击，三名学生被捕的消息迅速传开。其中特别令人震惊的是……
involvement of Bobby Johnson, the friendly teen who was well known for her involvement in the school theatre. As reported in the Associated Press, the Reigns High School superintendent said, these were students who had not been in trouble a great deal, maybe some tardies and absences, but that's it. State prosecutor Lisa Tanner continued to gather evidence to prove the extent of Aaron's involvement in the murders. Phone records revealed that Aaron had called Charlie's cell phone repeatedly in a short burst in the early hours of Saturday morning. This corresponded with Charlie's version of events that after Aaron restrained Max for them, she then called Charlie many times, asking where they were and when they were coming back.
据《美联社》报道，博比·约翰逊的参与程度，这位友好的少年因参与学校戏剧而广为人知。雷恩斯高中校长表示：“这些学生平时并没有惹出什么大麻烦，可能就是偶尔迟到和旷课，仅此而已。”州检察长丽莎·坦纳继续搜集证据，以证明艾伦在谋杀案中的涉案程度。通话记录显示，在周六清晨的短短一段时间内，艾伦曾多次拨打查理的手机。这与查理对事件经过的描述相吻合：在艾伦为他们控制住麦克斯之后，她给查理打了许多电话，询问他们在哪里以及什么时候回来。
Aaron was at a loss to explain the records, given that she maintained she was in bed asleep. Additionally, both Charles Wade and Bobby Johnson admitted that Aaron was the one responsible for the murders. From the book Terror by Night by Terry Caffey, Aaron had spoken to them for a month about the killings, saying she wanted her parents dead because she was so angry at them for not condoning her relationship with Charlie. As for her siblings, she told the pair that she wanted Matthew killed because he would talk and Tyler killed because she just didn't like him. Charlie, Charles and Bobby all maintained that they had tried to talk Aaron out of the murders in the lead-up, suggesting that she ran away with Charlie instead, that Aaron insisted she
艾伦对这些记录无言以对，因为她一直坚称自己当时在床上睡觉。此外，查尔斯·韦德和博比·约翰逊都承认艾伦才是谋杀案的幕后主谋。根据特里·卡菲所著的《黑夜恐怖》一书中记载，艾伦曾与他们谈论谋杀案长达一个月之久，称她希望父母死，因为她非常生父母的气，他们不支持她和查理的关系。至于她的兄弟们，她对两人说，她想杀害马修，因为他会到处乱说，她想杀害泰勒，纯粹是因为她不喜欢他。查理、查尔斯和博比都坚称，他们在事发前曾试图劝说艾伦放弃谋杀，建议她和查理私奔，但艾伦坚持认为她……
wanted them dead. She told them that her parents repeatedly punched and slapped her. However, all teens admitted that they had never seen any markings on Aaron to prove her allegations. The most startling revelation came from Michael Washburn, an ex-boyfriend Aaron had been seeing very casually prior to meeting Charlie. Aaron had also called this relationship off at the behest of her parents who didn't approve. When questioned by detectives, Michael said Aaron had confided in him that she was going to hire someone to go to her house and kill her parents. Aaron told him it was because every time she got a boyfriend that she really liked, her mum and dad tried to break them up.
想要他们死。她告诉他们，她的父母曾多次殴打和掌掴她。然而，所有青少年都承认，他们从未在艾伦身上看到任何能证明她指控的伤痕。最令人震惊的爆料来自迈克尔·沃什伯恩，他是艾伦在认识查理之前曾非常随性地交往过的前男友。这段恋情也是在父母的要求下被艾伦断绝的，因为父母不赞成。当被侦探讯问时，迈克尔说艾伦曾向他吐露，她打算雇人去她家杀害她的父母。艾伦告诉他，这是因为每当她交到一个真正喜欢的男朋友时，她的爸爸妈妈就会试图拆散他们。
In a decision that stunned many people, Terry chose to visit Aaron. As soon as he was well enough, he drove the 40-minute journey from where he was residing at his sister's house to the detention centre where she was being held. Separated by a thick piece of plexiglass, the father and daughter saw each other for the first time since the attack. Terry was concerned by Aaron's appearance, she looked pale and exhausted. He asked if she was being looked after, to which Aaron responded, yes. Forbidden to talk about the case before it went to trial, the two made small talk and tearily reminisced about old times. When nobody could overhear, Aaron told Terry she had tried to
在一个让许多人感到震惊的决定中，特里选择去探望艾伦。一等身体状况允许，他就从妹妹家驱车40分钟，来到了关押艾伦的拘留中心。父亲和女儿隔着一块厚厚有机玻璃，见到了自袭击发生以来的第一面。特里的心情很沉重，艾伦看上去脸色苍白、精疲力竭。他问她是否得到了照顾，艾伦回答说：是的。由于在案件审判前被禁止谈论案情，两人只好闲聊了几句，并含泪回忆起过去的旧时光。趁着无人偷听，艾伦告诉特里，她曾试图……
stop the attack, but it had gotten out of hand. Terry believed her. From terror by night, Terry wrote the following entry in his journal. I never thought that I would lose my entire family in one night and be all alone at the age of 41. Aaron is all that I have left and I will stand by her side no matter what. I know she needs me and I need her. I believe God saved my life that night for a reason and one of those reasons is to be here for her. I couldn't imagine her going through this without anyone, so I stand by her side and pray every day. There are a lot of questions that I have about that night and some of those questions may never be answered in this lifetime.
阻止这场袭击，但事情失控了。特里相信了她。摘自《黑夜恐怖》，特里在日记中写下了以下内容：“我从未想过我会在一夜之间失去整个家庭，在41岁时变得孤苦伶仃。艾伦是我仅剩的一切，无论发生什么，我都将站在她这一边。我知道她需要我，我也需要她。我相信上帝那天晚上救了我的命是有原因的，其中一个原因就是让我在这里陪伴她。我无法想象她独自经历这一切，所以我站在她身边，每天为她祈祷。关于那个夜晚，我有很多疑问，其中一些疑问可能在这个一生中永远得不到解答。”
One thing that I do believe is that Aaron loved her family and wouldn't want us dead. I believe they came that night and things went bad very fast and she had no control in it. So I keep trusting God to see us through and that in the end he will get the victory and that his will be done. The callousness of the attack stunned state prosecutor Lisa Turner. On Killer Women with Piers Morgan, she discussed how horrified she was that the four of them sat together for over an hour prior to the murders and not one of them brought up that perhaps they shouldn't follow through. She was flummoxed that they thought they would get away with it and there would be no repercussions
“我坚信的一点是，艾伦深爱着她的家人，绝不会希望我们死。我相信他们那天晚上来到这里，事情急转直下，而她对此毫无控制力。所以我继续信任上帝会带领我们度过难关，并最终取得胜利，愿他的旨意得到成就。”袭击事件的冷血无情让州检察长丽莎·特纳大为震惊。在《皮尔斯·摩根之杀人女性》节目中，她谈到自己感到无比震惊的是，这四个人在谋杀发生前坐在一起商量了一个多小时，竟然没有一个人提出也许他们不应该付诸行动。她感到十分困惑，他们怎么会以为自己能逃脱法网，而且……
for their actions. The prosecution sought the death penalty for both Charlie Wilkinson and Charles Wade. Because Aaron was a minor, she escaped a possible death penalty. Still, the prosecution wanted Aaron tried as an adult. This meant that she could still face a maximum sentence of life without the possibility of parole. Terry Caffey was for the death penalty for both Charles and Charlie, looking Lisa Tanner dead in the eyes and saying, Charlie ate at my table. As for Aaron, Terry hoped she would be tried as a minor instead of an adult as he didn't want her in an adult prison. In the juvenile detention center, Aaron met with Israel Lewis
他们的行为不会产生任何后果。检方对查理·威尔金森和查尔斯·韦德均寻求死刑判处。由于艾伦是一名未成年人，她逃脱了被判处死刑的可能。尽管如此，检方仍希望将艾伦作为成年人进行审判。这意味着她仍可能面临不得假释的终身监禁这一最高刑罚。特里·卡菲赞成对查尔斯和查理判处死刑，他直视着丽莎·坦纳的眼睛说：“查理曾在我的饭桌上吃过饭。”至于艾伦，特里希望她能作为未成年人而不是成年人接受审判，因为他不想让她进成人监狱。在少年拘留中心，艾伦会见了伊斯雷尔·刘易斯……
and experienced mental health counsellor hired to evaluate her for the defense. She told Lewis that she had been framed by Charlie who had a volatile temper. With tears in her eyes, she told Lewis many times, I'm innocent, God will save me. As Lewis became familiar with the intricacies of the crime, he realized he had been played by Aaron. He told the Texas Monthly, I have worked with some good liars that Aaron Caffey was one of the best. She seemed totally sincere and genuine and I would have put my license on the line to say that she was telling me the truth. I cried every time I left her jail cell.
他是一位经验丰富的心理健康顾问，受聘为辩护方对她进行评估。她告诉刘易斯，自己是被脾气暴躁的查理陷害的。她眼中含着泪水，多次对刘易斯说：“我是无辜的，上帝会救我的。”随着刘易斯对案件复杂细节的了解加深，他意识到自己被艾伦玩弄了。他告诉《德克萨斯月刊》：“我曾与一些善于说谎的人共事，但艾伦·卡菲是其中最优秀的一个。她表现得极其真诚自然，我甚至愿意拿我的执照作担保，说她对我说的是实话。每次离开她的牢房时，我都痛哭流涕。”
Father's Day in June 2008 marked three months since the murders. It was an extremely difficult time of year for Terry Caffey. On that day, he received a letter from his only living child, it read, Dear Daddy, let me start by saying Happy Father's Day. I hope you get this before then, but I don't need a date to tell you that you have been an awesome dad. You have done a great job and not for one second do I think different. None of this was your fault. If anything, it was mine. I feel like I don't deserve your love and that I let you and mama down. But in this family, we stick together and I have always loved you, mama and the boys very, very much.
2008年6月的父亲节标志着谋杀案发生已经三个月了。对特里·卡菲来说，这是一年中极其艰难的一段时期。那天，他收到了他唯一的在世孩子写的一信，信中写道：“亲爱的爸爸，请允许我先祝你父亲节快乐。我希望你能在这之前收到这封信，但我不需要一个特定的日子来告诉你，你一直是个了不起的爸爸。你做得很好，我一秒钟都没有改变过这种想法。这都不是你的错。如果要说有错，那也是我的错。我觉得我不配得到你的爱，我觉得我让你和妈妈失望了。但在这个家里，我们永远在一起，我一直非常、非常爱着你、妈妈和男孩们。”
I never wanted any of this to happen. I was just going with what he was telling me. He was feeding me all these lies. I got caught up in him and I feel so guilty. I'm glad that you're here with me now. If it wasn't for you, I don't know what would have happened to me. I love you. Even though this has happened, I still feel sad, but at the same time glad that I'm free from the pressure that was being put on me. I miss mama and the boys, but I know where they are. I know they would be proud of you. I am too. No matter what anyone says, you have been a great dad and did a great job of raising me. No matter where I go or who I'm around, I will never forget where I came from. And I dream one day of walking together in our property hand in hand. I do believe that
“我从来没想过会发生这一切。我只是顺着他告诉我的话去做。他一直在向我灌输所有这些谎言。我深陷其中，感到非常内疚。我很高兴你现在能陪在我身边。如果不是你，我不知道自己会变成什么样。我爱你。尽管发生了这一切，我仍然感到难过，但与此同时，我也很高兴自己终于摆脱了施加在我身上的压力。我想念妈妈和男孩们，但我知道他们在哪里。我知道他们会为你的表现感到骄傲。我也是。无论别人怎么说，你一直是个伟大的爸爸，把我抚养得很好。无论我去哪里，和谁在一起，我都永远不会忘记我来自哪里。我梦想有一天我们能手挽手一起走在我们家的土地上。我相信那……”
will happen. Anyway, I love you and happy Father's Day. Keep the faith. God's about to show us his mercy. Love, Aaron. Terry's eyes filled with tears as he read the letter. It reaffirmed his decision to always be around for his daughter. On June 26, 2008, there was a very brief certification hearing to determine whether Aaron would be tried as an adult. The district attorney argued that Aaron should stand trial as an adult and was a danger to both herself and the community. The judge agreed, and both Terry and Aaron cried as she was led away and transferred to Hopkins County Jail, where, due to her age, she was placed in protective custody to await trial. In October that year, Terry Caffey had a change of heart. He wrote a letter to the
“一定会发生。总之，我爱你，父亲节快乐。保持信念。上帝就要向我们展现他的怜悯了。爱你的，艾伦。”特里读着这封信，双眼盈满泪水。它再次坚定了他在女儿身边不离不弃的决心。2008年6月26日，举行了一场非常短暂的鉴定听证会，以确定是否将艾伦作为成年人进行审判。地区检察官辩称，艾伦应作为成年人接受审判，因为她对她自己和社区都构成了危险。法官表示赞同，当艾伦被带走并转移到霍普金斯县监狱时，特里和艾伦都哭了。由于她的年龄，她被安置在保护性拘留所中等待审判。那年十月，特里·卡菲改变了心意。他写了一封信给……
Attorney General's office to request that the death penalty be taken off the table for Charlie Wilkinson and Charles Wade. Terry reasoned that there had been enough deaths already, and rather a life sentence without parole would give them a chance to show remorse and repentance. In meeting with Lisa Tanner the following day, Terry said to her, When it comes time for them to die, I want that to be in God's hands, not mine. Three months later, on January 2, 2009, Bobby Johnson and Aaron Caffey were sentenced for their roles in the murders after both pleaded guilty to three counts of capital murder. As an accomplice to murder who did not use a weapon, Bobby accepted a plea deal in exchange
总检察长办公室，请求对查理·威尔金森和查尔斯·韦德免除死刑。特里推断，已经有足够多的生命逝去了，相反，不得假释的终身监禁会给他们一个表现出悔意和忏悔的机会。在第二天与丽莎·坦纳会面时，特里对她说：“到了他们该死的时候，我希望那是掌握在上帝手中，而不是我的手中。”三个月后，即2009年1月2年，博比·约翰逊和艾伦·卡菲因在谋杀案中所扮演的角色而被判刑，此前两人均对三项重大谋杀罪名认罪。作为一名未使用武器的谋杀共犯，博比接受了一项认罪协议，以换取……
for a trial and received a 40-year sentence with the possibility of parole in 20. Prosecutor Lisa Tanner requested that Aaron serve three life sentences with an additional 50 years, meaning she would never see the world outside of a prison. After some negotiation with Terry, Aaron signed a plea bargain for a sentence of two life sentences and an additional 25 years with the possibility of parole. Four days later, Charlie Wilkinson and Charles Wade faced sentencing. Both teens also avoided a trial because they had already pleaded guilty. A trial would have only been conducted to ascertain whether they were to receive the
免于受审，并被判处40年监禁，20年后可获得假释。检察官丽莎·坦纳要求判处艾伦三个终身监禁外加50年徒刑，这意味着她将永远无法重见监狱外的世界。在与特里进行了一些协商后，艾伦签署了一项认罪协议，刑期为两个终身监禁外加25年徒刑，并有假释的可能。四天后，查理·威尔金森和查尔斯·韦德面临宣判。这两名青少年也免于接受审判，因为他们已经认罪。原本审判的唯一目的就是确定他们是否应该被判处……
death penalty or life imprisonment because the death penalty had been taken off the table that rendered a trial unnecessary. Before the formal sentencing, Terry met with both Charlie and Charles separately. Charles Wade expressed remorse for what he had done, saying he only agreed to the plan because he needed the money promised to him by Aaron and Charlie to pay for court fees. He was trying to gain custody of his children. As mentioned in Terror by Night, Terry Caffey asked him, So you were willing to kill children to get children? Where's the logic in that? Charles Wade shook his head and said, I really don't know. I can't answer that. I have kids of my own.
死刑还是终身监禁，但由于死刑已经被取消，这使得审判变得没有必要。在正式宣判前，特里分别会见了查理和查尔斯。查尔斯·韦德对自己的所作所为表示了悔意，称他之所以同意这个计划，是因为他需要艾伦和查理承诺给他的钱来支付诉讼费。他当时正试图争夺自己孩子的抚养权。正如《黑夜恐怖》中所提到的，特里·卡菲问他：“所以你为了得到孩子，宁愿去杀害别人的孩子？这其中的逻辑在哪里？”查尔斯·韦德摇了摇头说：“我真的不知道。我回答不了这个问题。我也有自己的孩子。”
When Terry spoke with Charlie, he also expressed remorse for his actions. His eyes whirled with tears and he hung his head, refusing to make eye contact. He told Terry he did it out of love for Aaron. In the courtroom, Terry read a victim impact statement to Charlie and Charles. excerpts read, At first I had so much anger, so much bitterness towards you, but in time, God has shown me what it means to forgive. So I want to say to you today, I forgive you, not so much for your sake, but for my own. I refuse to grow into a bitter old man. If I am going to heal and move on,
当特里与查理交谈时，他也对自己的行为表达了悔意。他眼里含着泪水，垂下头，拒绝与特里对视。他告诉特里，他这么做是出于对艾伦的爱。在法庭上，特里向查理和查尔斯宣读了一份受害人影响陈述。节选内容如下：“起初我有那么多的愤怒，对你们有那么多的怨恨，但随着时间推移，上帝让我明白了宽恕的意义。所以今天我想对你们说，我原谅你们，与其说是为了你们，不如说是为了我自己。我拒绝让自己变成一个满腹怨恨的老头。如果我要疗愈并继续生活，……”
I must find forgiveness in my heart. That has been the hardest thing that I've ever had to do, because you have taken so much away from me. You took my wife of 18 years, whom I'll never be able to see or talk to again. You took my boys away from me. Matthew, only 13 years old. Tyler, only eight years old. Because of you, I'll never be able to see my boys grow up. Then, after you took my family away, you didn't stop there. You burned our house down, taking from me all my family photos, all the little special gifts and cards, all the things that were so precious to me. But, in spite of your hatred and evil efforts, I'll carry on with all the wonderful memories
“我必须在心中找到宽恕。那是我做过最艰难的事情，因为你们从我身边夺走了太多。你们夺走了我相伴18年的妻子，我再也无法见到她，也无法再与她说话。你们夺走了我的男孩们。马修，年仅13岁。泰勒，年仅8岁。因为你们，我再也无法看到我的男孩们长大成人。然后，在你们夺走我的家人之后，你们并没有就此收手。你们烧毁了我们的房子，夺走了我所有的家庭照片，所有那些特殊的小礼物和卡片，所有对我而言无比珍贵的东西。但是，尽管你们充满了仇恨和邪恶的企图，我仍将带着所有美好的回忆继续前行，……”
that will forever be ingrained in my heart. And that is something you will never be able to take from me. Both Charlie Wilkinson and Charles Wade were sentenced to life imprisonment without the possibility of parole. In April 2009, Terry Caffey became an ordained minister. He has spent countless hours telling his story in churches, schools and prisons to encourage people to make good choices and forgive others. Following the murders, Terry found Max a new and loving home, unable to care for his family dog due to his state of health. Once a month, Terry makes the six-hour round trip from his new home to visit Aaron at the Texas Department of Criminal Justice Women's Prison at Gatesville. Whilst Terry believes that Aaron must have had some degree of participation in the murders,
这些回忆将永远铭刻在我的心中。而这是你们永远无法从我这里夺走的。查理·威尔金森和查尔斯·韦德均被判处不得假释的终身监禁。2009年4月，特里·卡菲成为了一名受按立的牧师。他花无数的时间在教堂、学校和监狱里讲述自己的故事，鼓励人们做出正确的选择并宽恕他人。谋杀案发生后，由于身体健康状况无法继续照顾家犬，特里为麦克斯找到了一个充满爱意的新家。每个月一次，特里会从新家出发，进行长达六小时的往返行程，前往得克萨斯州刑事司法部盖茨维尔女子监狱探望艾伦。虽然特里相信艾伦一定在谋杀案中参与了一定程度的行动，……
he doesn't believe that she was the ringleader, nor that she wanted her family dead. I think she thought Charlie was just blowing smoke. I don't think she actually thought he would go through with it. I know my daughter. She cried one time when we were in my truck and I ran over a squirrel. She's tender-hearted. No kids and angel, but I know what she is capable of, and I know she's not capable of murder. I don't know if she is capable of murder, but I don't know if she is capable of, and I know she's not capable of murder. Aaron also still denies being the mastermind behind the attack, alleging that she wanted to run away, but the others forced her to stay in the car while they carried out the murders. She has even appeared on the Doctor Phil show via
但他不认为她是团伙首领，也不认为她希望她的家人死去。“我想她以为查理只是在说说大话。我不认为她真的以为他会付诸行动。我了解我的女儿。我们在卡车里时，我碾死了一只松鼠，她都哭过。她心肠很软。她虽然不是什么完美的乖乖女，但我知道她能做什么，我也知道她没有能力杀人。我不知道她是否有能力杀人，但我不知道她是否有能力做出那种事，而且我知道她没有能力谋杀。”艾伦至今仍然否认自己是袭击事件的幕后主谋，坚称自己只想私奔，但其他人强迫她留在车里，而他们则实施了谋杀。她甚至通过……
prison to defend herself. On Killer Women with Piers Morgan, Aaron said she's no longer in love with Charli Wilkinson, whom she has not seen or spoken to since their arrest. With good behavior, Aaron could be out on parole at 59 years of age. Aaron says the first thing she will do when she gets out of prison is go to the gravesites of her mother Penny and brothers Matthew and Tyler to pay her respects. Charli Wilkinson was incarcerated in the Polanski unit in Livingston. He questioned whether Aaron ever loved him or if he was just a pawn she could order about. He told the Texas Monthly that I would have done anything for her. She was very smart, very caring. I don't know why she wanted it done, why it had to be done like that,
监狱视频出面在《菲尔博士》节目上为自己辩护。在《皮尔斯·摩根之杀人女性》节目中，艾伦表示她不再爱查理·威尔金森了，自他们被捕以来，她就再也没有见过他，也没有和他说过话。如果表现良好，艾伦在59岁时就可以获得假释出狱。艾伦说，她出狱后做的第一件事就是去她的母亲彭妮以及兄弟马修和泰勒的墓地去表达敬意。查理·威尔金森被关押在利文斯顿的波兰斯基收容所。他质疑艾伦是否真的爱过他，或者他只是她可以呼之即来挥之即去的棋子。他告诉《德克萨斯月刊》：“为了她，我什么都愿意做。她很聪明，很体贴。我不知道她为什么非要这样做，为什么事情非要弄成那样，……”
but she was a very nice person. When asked if he still loved Aaron, Charli responded, once you love somebody, you can't quit. You always will. In the aftermath of the murders, Terry Caffey considered taking his life, unable to deal with the despair of losing his family. He desperately searched for a sign from God for any kind of guidance to help him move forward. Six weeks after the attack, he found it. Terry stood amongst the rubble where his house used to be. Bulldozers had cleared most of the debris and leveled out the block. Out of the corner of his eye, he spotted a piece of paper that had blown against the trunk of a nearby pine tree. The paper, burnt black around the edges,
“但她是个非常善良的人。”当被问及是否还爱着艾伦时，查理回答说：“一旦你爱上一个人，你就无法戒掉。你永远都会爱着。”谋杀案发生后，特里·卡菲曾考虑过结束自己的生命，因为他无法承受失去家人的绝望。他绝望地寻找来自上帝的迹象，希望能得到任何形式的指引来帮助他继续生活。袭击发生六周后，他找到了。特里站在他昔日房屋的废墟之中。推土机已经清理了大部分的残骸，并将这片地块推平。在他眼角的余光中，他发现了一张被风吹到附近一棵松树树干上的纸片。这张纸边缘被熏黑，……
had survived the fire and the subsequent clearing of the land. It was from a book owned by his wife. The first few lines of the page were of one of the book's characters talking to God. It read, I couldn't understand why you would take my family and leave me to struggle along without them. And I guess I still totally don't understand that part of it. But I do believe that you're sovereign. You're in control. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它在火灾以及随后的土地清理中幸存了下来。它来自他妻子拥有的一本书。页面上的前几行是书中一个角色在与上帝对话。上面写道：“我无法理解你为什么会夺走我的家人，却留下我让他们艰难地独自面对这一切。我想我仍然完全无法理解那部分。但我确实相信你是至高无上的。你在掌控一切。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。”